I'm such a huge fan of you and and I
started watching the show when I was a
kid and I mean like I I've told you this
before but you and Conan like shaped my
not that I'm so much younger than you
but I was in that formative but you're
younger than me I am yeah yeah but I
mean and we weren't that old when we got
on TV for the first time so you guys
really really shaped my comedic
sensibility and sort of showed me what
I've talked about this especially with
like real Conan and Andy heads like like
Drew Tarver do you know Drew Tarver
we've talked I do too we've talked about
it if I could put like if I could put
money on somebody just in terms of like
that guy's gonna be huge oh I drew
totally agree I would buy stock and
drink Carver all day too he's he's
wonderful and hasn't even like
like as as great as you've seen him he
has more yeah yeah I absolutely but he
and I have talked about how you know
becoming obsessed with you guys at a at
a younger age like it was almost like a
language you would speak and if somebody
else spoke that language it was like a
shared yeah you know Letterman was that
yeah exactly or like Monty Python or
something like that where you're like oh
you you get that too great we we see the
same like we we are the same we have the
same sense of humor and and which was so
nice as like a weird young kid oh it's I
mean and it's the thing that the work
thing that I am probably proudest of
yeah is is
having the effect on people younger than
me who are serious about comedy I.E me
yeah just younger yeah and then and then
being a formative influence on people
now out being formative influences on
other people it's just it's you know you
can't even yeah it's like you say it's
like it's like
you know UCB being grad school like this
is like it's it's like being a professor
emeritus of Comedy too or something yeah
no it's too big to like wrap your head
around I think yeah because it's really
I don't I don't I can't I know and you
shouldn't actually yeah yeah of course
but I'm very proud of it and I and I
have to make myself remind myself just
given the date that how every minute has
60 seconds in it I have to remind myself
no no you you know you're not you know
you're not the lazy slob that you think
you are you're the one who's yeah you've
actually done something yeah you've done
some things
you sure have you sure yeah you're cool
but yeah it's uh it is
being in that position has been uh I've
gotten to watch a lot of Showbiz
happening yeah over the years yeah and I
mean and I you know it's interesting to
then you start to do it and it is kind
of like well
I think and you touched on it too the
amount of real people like people that
you meet and you're like okay I'm
talking to the person you know then
that's kind of it's surprisingly rare
you know I know it's nice yeah when you
see that you're like oh no that's I mean
I I say that about about the people
you've mentioned like Henry people
always say is Henry Winkler really as
nice as he seems and he is he's even
better he's even better because he like
because he's realer he cares more yeah
Henry Henry I I just did a Broadway play
in New York City America yes it was the
Thanksgiving Thanksgiving Place yeah and
Henry would call me every Monday because
he knew that was like the day we were
off just to check in how did this week
of shows go what did you learn what did
what happened what did who you know it
was like it he really is like yeah he's
he's all that you hope he is but then
also more because it's not surfacy
um I love him so much I just it's
hilarious that he was Fonzy I know like
of all the people that you could pick to
be like the supernatural cool guy that
can start machines by pop by punching
them
Henry I love it yeah it's really
fantastic